die deutsche bank braucht dringend ein
neues image umso seltsamer für nicht
dass ausgerechnet der kollege ulrich von
heesen bei denen jetzt die neue pr
abteilung leitet er hat sein büro hinter
am frankfurter hauptbahnhof
warum wegen der streetwear alter wir
sehen dass verbrecher images als chance
so ein spießiges bauspar opfer wie du
welche der freut sich über null prozent
auf dem sparbuch raiffeisenbank coole
jungs bringen ihr geld zum gangster zu
mir
die deutsche bank ist jetzt eine
motorradgang hier werden uns die bank
den bandidos somit wagen ja hat nicht
verstanden
der iwf nennt uns die gefährlichste band
der welt wir haben so viele vorstrafen
wenn wir kommen da geht sogar der uli
hoeneß auf die andere straßenseite alter
die liste der vorwürfe die ist ziemlich
lang da geht es zum beispiel um
manipulationen von währungen um dubiose
hypotheken-geschäfte in bei den meisten
großen finanzskandalen der vergangenen
jahre war die deutsche bank dabei kurz
gesagt welche wir sind die schlimmsten
ns massaker im ganzen fucking business
keine deutsche firma ist krimineller als
sie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
4.2 mitzureden
oder wie wir uns seit neuestem nennen
die suns aufstieg vw ist auch eine
motorradgang motorräder wir fahren was
viel schlimmer dass das gefährlichste
fahrzeug der welt einen passat
bluemotion diese möchtegern gangster mal
auspuff matschie in stinky wir können
morgen die ganze weltwirtschaft
vernichten wenn mein boss beim frühstück
ein zahmes wackeln in japan die börse
alter wenn mein auto einen fahren lässt
sterben in stuttgart die rentner
wir haben mit unserer beschissen
die marke made in germany durchs klo
gespült
ich wohne gleich die deutsche bank hat
aktuell 7800 prozess anna wacker stand
22 auf 40 liegen werden acht in der
breite
wir zahlen us-kunden entschädigung
deutscher vw-fahrer kriegen gar nichts
weil wir die haxen und erotik auf die
unsere texte trotzdem weiter einigen uns
darauf folgenden kompromiss beide firmen
sind wahnsinnig unsympathisch und haben
dieses jahr echt scheiße gebaut
frankfurt ist zu klein für uns weil wir
das jetzt auf gute alte art mit einem
messer kampf auf leben und tod
jetzt mit messer nein wir sind eine
senioren motorrad-gang wie meine waffe
dann lass mal kommen mit rosalie ich hau
dir die zähne bisher wolfsburg nun
feinstaub das magazin antreffen
das führt zu spannend ölriesen und
gelber fleck
[Applaus]